il y a eu il y a eu il y a eu un trou de
15 ans et et et on s'est perdu de vue
mon père ne me connaît pas je le connais
pas alors Anthony DeLand c'est vrai que
ça vous exprimz rarement comme ça à la
télévision on vous on vous voit peu mais
je crois que vous avez envie finalement
de vous montrer tel que vous êtes
vraiment parce qu'à un moment vous en
avez marre de des rumeurs des ragots des
fausses images c'est c'est vrai que ça
fait longtemps que que je suis pas venu
à la télévision
je j'avais pris le parti de de venir
uniquement pour parler de de film
d'ailleurs je le fais aussi un peu ce
soir parou un je de con qui sort bientôt
au cinéma on mais et puis voilà et puis
je suis content d'être là ce soir est
cont de voir en tout les cas vous ê
toujours voilà quoi donc bientôt nous
verrons Anthony de lond dans jeu de con
c'est un film de Jean-Michel Werner avec
Frédéric difental on va en parler mais
d'abord on va parler de votre vie je
dirais pas que c'est un jeu de con mais
il y a eu pas mal de conneries quand
[Applaudissements]
même
moi il y a tellement d'emails qui m'ont
dit Thierry sois gentil arrête de
chanter que dès qu'il y a un S pleur je
ferme ma gueule d'accord beaucoup plus
d'email qui t'ont dit kierry sois gentil
arrête
oui donc finalement c'est pas bien alors
Anthony Delon vous avez 36 ans vous êtes
né à Los Angeles vous êtes le fils
d'Alain Delon bien sûr et de Nathalie
Delon Nathalie Delon vit aux États-Unis
depuis depuis une vingtaine d'années
elle paraît qu'elle veut rentrer en
France oui alors pas si les gens se
souviennent parce que les gens peut-être
ont pas connu Nathalie Delon cétait un
couple absolument extraordinaire votre
père et votre mère parce qu'il se
ressemblaient mais vraiment ils avaient
vraiment le même
look aussi
ressemble il y avait une ressemblance
parfaite et il s'habillait pareil vous
avez vu des photos de cette époque vous
pensez qu'ils étaient frères et sœurs
voilà c'était pas le cas non c'était pas
le cas assurez déjà ce soir on va tordre
le coup à toutes les rumeurs à tous les
scandales Nathalie Delon et Alain Delon
n'étent pas frères et sœurs voilà alors
vos parents divorce quand vous avez 4
ans euh c'est une fure pour vous parce
qu'on dit toujours que les divorces
finalement il vaut mieux des parents qui
divorcent que des parents qui
s'engueulent enfin on demande jamais la
vie des enfants et souvent quand on
interview des enfants qui ont vieilli
qui sont devenus adultes on s'aperçoit
que ça a été très douloureux pour eux
c'était le cas pour vous non parce que
moi c'est arrivé très jeune ils ont
divorcé quand j'avais 4 ans h donc en
fait je me souviens absolument pas
d'avoir vécu avec l'un et l'autre avant
ce cette période donc je je c'est pas
une des choses qui m'a le plus marqué je
dois dire alors vous aviez une nurse qui
s'appelait Loulou et hein loulou vous la
voyez toujours loulou je la vois
toujours oui bien sûr vous avez eu
quatre
enfants et puis un parrain qui est
George Baum qui est un agent historique
du cinéma français qui a été en fait
votre votre vrai père quoi non mon vrai
père c'est Alain Delon euh mais suis
biologique bien sûr George Baum c'était
c'est toujours mon Parin h donc si vous
voulait mon parrain était là c'est vrai
mon père a été là aussi ça a été
différent mais mon mon père travaillait
beaucoup mon Parin aussi mais il était
plus disponible il avait 20 ans de plus
en général plus on viit plus on est
disponible pour les gens qui sont
proches de nous et c'est vrai que j'ai
passé beaucoup de temps avec lui et
qu'il m'a appris beaucoup de choses
alors bon Alain Delon on connaît les les
problèmes que vous avez eu avec lui on
va pas y passer la soirée simplement lui
il a déclaré je voulais l'élever dans la
rigueur et la discipline il m'a échappé
il a refusé mon autorité pour une vie
plus facile vous vous êtes d'accord avec
ça non il veut la même chose que moi il
veut la même chose que tout père si vous
voulez c'estàdire qu'à partir du moment
où vous fondez une famille avec une
femme vous avez un enfant c'est l'osmose
c'est le trinô parfait et et et notre
seul désir qui est le mien aujourd'hui
puisque moi aussi je je suis père c'est
de de bah de réussir ma vie de famille
et d'essayer de de de rester uni le plus
longtemps possible et de de et d'y
arriver donc c'est vrai que la rupture
pour lui a été difficile pour nous pour
tout le monde et c'est vrai qu'il avait
probablement une idée bien précise de ce
qu'il avait envie de faire et il a pas
pu le faire pour moi parce que parce que
la vie on a décidé autrement et que que
et que normalement quand deux parents
divorcent l'enfant va avec sa mère ouais
ENF ce qu' l'a beaucoup choqué votre
père c'est que vous ayez été réformé
service militaire pour insuffisance
mentale et troues psychologique parce
que lui il avait fait la guerre quand
même en indchine comment vous savez ça
vous non ça l'a choqué que vous fassiez
réformer du service militaire écoutez je
sais pas on en a jamais parlé mais je me
suis fait réformer oui ouais mais
aujourd'hui vous avez envie de de régler
les problèmes un peu avec votre père
vous dites je ne voudrais pas enterrer
mon père sur des points de suspension
enterrer ça va pas le faire marrer
beaucoup mais je vous dit je voudrais
pas porter cela jusqu'à la fin de mes
jours ça me ferait vraiment trop mal ça
vous embêterait de de finalement que
votre père disparaisse avant que vous
soyez réconcilié mon père et moi bien
sûr qu'on s'est réconcilié quand je je
je dis ça je dis en fait il y a eu il y
a eu il y a eu un trou de 15 ans h et et
et on s'est perdu de vue mon père ne me
connaît pas je le connais pas et et
c'est vrai que le travail aujourd'hui
c'est pas de se de de se revoir et de se
reparler parce que ça c'est fait parce
que parce qu'on s'aime mais c'est
surtout de d'apprendre à se connaître et
de de de retrouver si vous voulez cette
union qui doit normalement exister entre
un père et un fils mais sans se
connaître ça prend du temps et puis et
puis lui il est comme il est moi je suis
comme je suis il y a un chacun chacun
votre caractère quand même donc c'est ça
si j'aimerais j'aimerais savoir qui il
est avant de l'enterrer s'il parle le
premier c'est quel jour là parce que
hein tu as la date de l'enterrement de
ton père c'est incroyable la façon dont
tu tu tu parles de ça tu sais parce que
on projette toujours et puis on se dit
un accident peut vite arriver regarde
par exemple ce soir tire un peu trop sur
la ficelle il peut y avoir un accident
montre-moi ta ficelle je va te dire je
vais te dire s'il peut y avoir un
accident bien alors non il y a eu des
histoires bon on souvient tous en 85
votre père vous interdit d'utiliser la
marque
ad pour vendre vos blousons en cuir vous
étiez en train de faire une une bonne
affaire parce que vous étiez je savais
pas deè devvant derrière MC
dououglas ça se passait bien j'ai pas en
fait non ça a été éit un peu déformé je
je la marque s'appelait pas elle
s'appelait Anthony Delon donc mon père
pouvait pas m'empêcher de le faire c'est
plutôt si vous voulez les gens avec qui
il a il a signé son contrat de licence
qui ont commencé à lui dire non mais
attendez votre fils il fait ça et cetera
et cetera vous étiez associé avec un
garçon qui était directeur de boîte de
nuit qui s'est fait tirer dessus à
l'époque qui s'appelait David torgem
vous étz convoqué à la à la brigade
criminelle ce qui a fait aussi que ça ça
a pas aidé cette cette affaire de
blouson rien n'a aidé non c'est sûr que
quand son associé se fait flinguer dans
sa voiture c'est pas ça fait des ordres
pe donc après on a eu des impayés et
puis on a déposé le bilan ouais alors
vous aviez été interpellé 2 ans avant
avant cette affaire donc en 83 dans une
BMW volée et dans la boîte à Gan il y
avait le pistolet volé à un policier
lors de l'évasion de Bruno sulac qui
était l'ennemi public numéro
1 j'ai piqué la mauvaise bagnole ouais
alors votre père est venu vous chercher
à la prison et vous avez pas été sympa
parce quand il est venu vous chercher à
la prison vous avez dit il vient me
chercher pour se faire de la pub
ça lui a pas plu était fâché était pas
content non j'ai dit ça parce que j'ai
dit ça parce que j'ai vu dans la photo
qui était je pense en couverture de de
match je crois ou ailleurs un
photographe qui était son photographe
personnel à l'époque et qui était là
alors je me suis dit qu'est-ce qu'il
fout là donc si vous voulez j'en ai
déduit que que que ouais quand vous êtes
arrivé dans la prison dans la cellule on
vous a dit il y avait un type là un
youoslave qui s'est pendu il y a
quelques jours hier hier il a il a cassé
les vitres ça s bien goupillé au niveau
de bah tu sais en prison en France on n
pas beaucoup de place ça fait de la
place donc ça fait de la place dès qu'il
y en a un qui dégage on met l'autre à la
place quoi sérieux là vous êtes dit
quand même là je su Allis un peu loin
quand même non je me suis dit merde
pourquoi ils m'ont mis dans cette
cellule et puis surtout que les fenêtres
étaient cassées il faisaient un froid de
canard je non tout ça a commencé vous
avez fait une fugue en fait au départ
parce que vous annoncez à votre père que
vous êtes photographe c'est comme ça que
ça a commencé la dissension entre vous
et il dit je vais t'envoyé en maison de
correction en Pologne ou en Yougoslavie
c'est vrai
que j'ai je j'ai arrêté l'école je
voulais plus aller à l'école je la
première année de de donc de première le
premier jour la première heure je
m'assois en classe et le type commence à
parler je suis là et je me dis
j'en peux plus c'est fini ouais faut que
je me casse donc j'ai dis monsieur oui
est-ce que je peux aller aux toilette
s'il vous plaît donc je suis sorti à ce
moment-là je tombe sur le directeur qui
s'appelait mosketti qui était mon
directeur à à charlemine parce que
j'étais aussi à charlemine on a essayé
de me visser là-bas il me dit Deon
qu'est-ce que vous faites là je dis
monsieur j'ai mal aux couilles j'ai
demandé à sortir ça c'est véridique il
me dit assayez-vous ça va passer je vais
vous faire un petit
massage j'avais 17 ans il s dit c'est
normal elles sont pleines il est parti
et puis dès qu'il a tourné la porte et
j'ai dit c'est fini je veux plus tu peux
pas arrêter machin pour faire quoi et
puis je sais pas pourquoi j'ai dit
photograp
ouais photographe donc là votre père
vous dit j'aurais pu dire n'importe quoi
ouais je vais te mettre en maison de
correction en Pologne en youoslavie et
là vous vous retrouvez seul dans un
appartement à Paris prêté par une
danseuse du du Crazy Horse qui était
parti effectivement j'étais un peu lâché
dans la nature ma mère bon vivait aux
États-Unis mon père et moi c'était
c'était la brouille donc je me suis
retrouvé comme ça et puis j'hitaé à
droite à gauche et des copains et cetera
jusqu'au jour où effectivement cette
fille qui a décroché un contrat de
danseuse au Crazy au Mexique nous a
laissé son appartement sympa les filles
du
Crazy donc on était dans l'appart j'
était là dans l'appart il se demandait
qu'est-ce qu'on va mettre dans le frigo
voililà qu'est-ce qu'on va mettre dans
le frigo donc effectivement on fait des
conneries ouais bon après vous êtes un
peu défoncé après non mais bon bien
après bien après hein entre 20 et 30
ouais et après bien sûr la prostitution
pourtant vous avez non non l'engrenage
la prostitution en général c'est pendant
comm non mais pourtant vous aiez eu du
succès au cinéma c'est ça qui est assez
incompréhensible c'est dans chronique
d'une mort annoncé le film de de Rossy
vous aviez eu beaucoup de succès les
critiques avaient salué votre talent
Rosy c'était bien c'était bien
d'ailleurs c'est le premier qu'on a vu
c'est le premier qui est sorti on a été
à Cann pour ça et effectivement ouais
j'avais bien démarré
euh mais ça a coïncidait avec justement
le moment où où je me suis j'ai commencé
à à déconner h et derrière ça euh
j'avais plus envie de travailler je
faisais des conneries je je me défonçais
je faisais voilà et puis 2 ans après on
m'a dit mon mon agent à l'époque m'a dit
tu sais il faut que tu tournes parce
qu'on va t'oublier et j'ai fait la femme
fardé et là vous étiez tellement bourré
que c'était pas terrible et là j'étais
tellement bourré que que que c'était pas
terrible et à ce moment-là je me suis
fait je me suis fait casser c'est normal
ouais vous avez pris conscience quand et
comment qu'il fallait arrêter la
daupe j'ai pris conscience ben le jour
où où je je me suis rendu compte que bah
que j'étais devenu un esclave et que la
la daupe m'avait pris ma liberté et ma
dignité alors aujourd'hui ça va bien
vous êtes avec Sophie vous avez une
petite fille qui s'appelle lou'pp lou
vous avez fait une psychothérapie j'ai
fait une psychothérapie analytique ouais
pendant pendant pendant 2 ans puis
ensuite par moment je retournais le voir
pour pour parler pour et là c'est
réglé ouais mais après ça devient comme
un ça devient un ami ça devient un
membre de la famille tu euh je peux
avoir envie de lui parler je l'appelle
je lui parle c'est bien parce que c'est
tout un c'est c'est gratos maintenant
c'est un pote c'est jamais gratos euh
après c'est une c'est une c'est une
gymnastique quand on arrive quand on a
du mal à parler à ses amis ou même à se
parler à soi on s'assoit puis c'est tout
un un un truc qui est en route et puis
paf ça aide quoi si c'était à refaire je
le referaai tout pareil tout pareil même
la DO tout c'est marrant chez les delons
pourquoi il y a ce goût comme ça un peu
du du côté gangster un peu parce que
quand on lit quand on lit la biographie
de votre père même siil est pas autorisé
ce qui est sorti est pas complètement
faux il aimit bien joue avec des
revolvers tout ça ça vient d'où ça par
rapport aux Belmondo qui sont très
rangés c'est vrai en plus c'est
[Applaudissements]
vrai e c'est vrai que pas Belmondo il
est hein ils sont sages des gens qui se
droguent pas bah oui alors réponds ça
bien
[Musique]
euh lui lui euh il aime les armes il les
a il les a toujours aimé je c'est comme
ça moi j'aime j'aime plus tellement ça
en fait je crois que moi j'ai été un
petit peu et c'est normal j'ai grandi
avec le culte d'un père qui était qui
était acteur mais qui était surtout euh
euh la star la star la plus grande star
française pendant 25 ans et puis qui est
était toujours un flic ou un voyou un
flic ou un voyou il a toujours un fling
dans les MSAN ou un Zoro ou un gitan ou
un Zoro mais bon ouais donc oui c'est ça
c'est une limitation de l'image du père
en fait c'est normal il y a le mimétisme
toujours qui qui fait que quand on vous
voit dans dans ce film on regrette que
finalement après le la chronique d'une
mort annoncée vous ayez pas continuer
merci et alors ce qui est très bien
c'est que vous êtes souvent dans
l'autodérision et c'est vrai qu'en plus
vous avez beaucoup de on sent quelque
chose de nouveau chez vous c'est que
vous avez de la la distance par rapport
à votre à votre personne ce que vous
êtes quoi et ça c'est nouveau c'est vrai
euh j'ai de la distance parce que ENF si
d'abord je me suis jamais pris au
sérieux mais att nous non plus on t'a
jamais pris au
sérieux je me suis jamais pris au
sérieux mais j'avais une distance plutôt
une distance par rapport en fait j'en
avais ralbol voilà j'en avais ralbol que
les gens se fasse une fausse idée parce
que c'est vrai que que ça fait 15 ans
que je me tais quand je dis je me tais
c'estd que bon on me demande toujours
faites une interview faites si faites là
et je le fais pas parce que parce que
j'avais pas envie et parce que bon pour
des raisons multiples et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui je je me suis dit mais
quand je rencontre quelqu'un on me dit
mais ah mais c'est drôle je pensais pas
que tu étais comme ça je pensais que tu
étais un con enfin ils le disent pas
mais ils le pensent tu vois ou que tu
étais prétentieux ou que tu étais ceci
que tu étais cela hein et
euh et en fait c'est c'est pas ça et et
à un moment j'ai dis faut faut je sais
pas F j'ai beaucoup changé aussi non
c'est vrai qu'il y a une époque où vous
non il y a une époque où vous fermiez
comme une hre ouais mais c'est venu
c'est venu de tout un une accumulation
de choses c'est venu de la femme fardée
où où je me suis fait massacrer après et
c'est vrai que je l'ai pris je l'ai pris
je l'ai pris en pleine gueule et que et
que j'ai pas j'avais 20 enfin j'avais 20
ans je veux dire à ce moment-là on n'est
pas capable de prendre du recul j'étais
j'étais en plein de dent et et et et et
j'ai donné le bâton pour me faire battre
et puis si on m'a on m'a allumé c'est
moi qui déconné c'est moi qui est bu
c'est moi qui a fait des conneries c'est
moi qui me suis défoncé c'est c'est de
ma faute mais si tu veux ma première
réaction elle a été le rejet ah ouais
vous moi je suis na dans ce film et tout
mais allez vous faire si je suis
na allez vous faire excuse-moi mais non
on est
chardissonétais un peu tendu par on est
chardisson mais il y a Hervé bourge ce
soir ok d'ailleurs HERV je lui demandé
de rentrer maintenant par allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Bienz Bour il est sur le
coup ta tout à l'HE
donc modérez vos propos d'accord on est
content de vous voir comme ça vous allez
mieux vous allez mieux dans votre peau
plus à l'aise c'est vrai je suis ce qui
est terrible c'est que là les excès que
vous avez fait vous ont pas
[Musique]
marqué bien alors
anthonon vous avez eu des haut vous avez
eu des bas on va faire l'interview
[Musique]
up sa tout le monde le sait bouge pas
pendant le
jingle bien alors Anthony Delon ce que
vous préférez en vous mes
mains ce que vous détestez en vous mon
père
l'anxiété ce que vous préférez au cinéma
rêver que vous haïsez au
cinéma la
complaisance le film de vous que vous
préférez je de con le film de vous que
vous
détestez il y en a
beaucoup l'pine dans le cœur le plus
grand moment de votre vie la naissance
de ma
fille des responsabilités de père de
famille maintenant c'est vrai que quand
on a on a un enfant on est on nous prend
enfin quelque part on se on est attaché
on est attaché à cet enfant bien sûr
mais on est attaché à à certaines choses
on a plus toutes les libertés c'est que
demain je peux pas prendre ma valise et
partir
et et
disparaître c'est bien vous trouvez ça
bien c'est bien mais c'est c'est dur
aussi ouais il y a quelqu'un qui a
besoin de vous maintenant ouais ce qui
vous plaît le plus dans la vie oh il y a
plein de choses qui me
plaisent j'aime être entre amis j'aime
j'aime aller au cinéma j'aime rire
beaucoup arrê tu vas trop loin déjà
c'est trop violent pour les gens
n'oublie pas qu' j'aime prendre ma fille
dans mes bras j'aime enfin j'ai tout
enfin jouir de la vie qui vous fait le
plus chier dans la vie les cons vre plus
gros coup de fric pour toi le crédit
lionnaire
raconte j'ai jamais eu de gros coup de
fric ouais votre plus grosse perte ma
plus grosse perte et ben ça sera
peut-être je de con parce que je de con
j'ai joué dedans mais j'ai produit aussi
qui vous fait le plus rire dans la
vie les trucs cons les gags le le le le
le enfin le le je sais pas Ngan qui
descend de l'avion et qui se VAE qui
attrape son son garde du corps qui tombe
avec lui enfin ce genre de truc quoi ça
me fait rire et le moins
rire les
drames tout ce que je vois à la
télé plus belle histoire d'amour ah ben
c'est celle-là ou non
c'estan sans déconner pcha nancyigane
et pas que
nanyigane incroyable votre histoire
d'amour la plus minable Bernadette
elle est très
chouette je sais plus y en a il y en a
eu plein il y en a eu plein enfin tu
sais le truc 5h du Matth tu rentres tu
bourré ce que vous vez de plus sexy en
vous elle a dit les yeux VO derrière dit
les couilles alors mettez-vous d'accord
[Applaudissements]
e on a failli échapper je sais on a
failli échapper si on plaisante HERV on
plaisante si si Pascal si Pascal céè
c'était pas cassé une côte et de moins
sexy je sais pas
moi B les filles dites quelque chose tu
tu es des gamines de 17 ans dans le
public il font les couilles vraiment le
monde a changé hein je sais pas moi les
genoux ouais voilà les genoux ouais ce
que vous préférez dans le sexe le
plaisir de l'autre ça fait bien de dire
ça à la télé he
bravo c'est un bon plan ou mais c'est un
bon plan pour choper ça en revanche
c'est le billon dit non mais le plaisir
de l'autre c'est aussi mon plaisir en
revanche nouie pas que ta femme va voir
l'émission et là tu Cu je sais cocou
tues pas couché toi ce que vous détestez
dans le sexe ce que je déteste c'est
c'est la pédophilie par exemple et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de inarditube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu